After six seasons, years of rich historical
drama and a great deal of ratings success,
what exactly made History decide to axe its
flagship show?
These are the real reasons why Vikings is
finally coming to an end.
Growing up on his parents' farm in Australia,
Travis Fimmel was a million miles away from
the bright lights of Hollywood, but a chance
encounter with a modeling scout changed the
course of his life forever.
After a stint working in London, he decided
to try his luck Stateside, and according to
the Sydney Morning Herald, was offered a contract
instantly after, quote, "swaggering barefoot
into LA Models."
He quickly became the face of Calvin Klein,
but while he made money posing in his underwear,
he was also fine-tuning his acting skills.
Fimmel had a number of roles in Australia
prior to Vikings, but it was playing the show's
enigmatic lead that brought him international
recognition.
His intense and often sympathetic portrayal
of farmer-turned-Viking leader Ragnar Lothbrok
was the true heart of the show, so when the
character was killed off in season 4, Vikings
entered uncharted territory.
According to Forbes writer Erik Kain, it was
a gamble that ultimately didn't pay off.
After the show’s cancellation, he wrote:
"Thank goodness.
The show has been lost at sea for a long time
now, and probably should have wrapped with
the death of Ragnar and departure of lead,
Travis Fimmel."
When Ragnar met his end in season 4, viewers
were supposed to get on board with the idea
of his sons heading to England to avenge his
death.
We were introduced to his first-born son,
Bjorn, way back in the first season, but we
didn't really get to know the rest of Ragnar's
brood until after the season 4 time jump.
Vikings creator Michael Hirst told Variety:
"It was very important to bring on Ragnar's
sons.
I've invested a lot of time, hope and expectation
in these sons.
It's very important that the audience invest
in these new characters."
Unfortunately for Hirst, this never really
happened.
Despite his best efforts, audiences just didn't
seem as interested in watching the antics
of Ragnar's offspring, even when they were
hell-bent on avenging the man himself.
After new of the show’s end broke, Forbes
reported:
"Ragnar's story was over a long time ago and
none of the stories that have come since have
resonated as much with viewers.”
TV Equals placed the blame directly at the
feet of Ragnar's sons.
They wrote:
"The death of Ragnar Lothbrok has left a void
that his sons have not yet been able to fill…
most of Ragnar's sons are kind of boring."
History ordered a sixth season of Vikings
before season 5 had even begun.
At the time, nobody knew that the sixth season
would be the last, but the decision to cancel
the show seems to have been influenced (at
least in part) by a decline in viewership.
Following the season 5 premiere, CarterMatt
tried to soften the blow by suggesting that
it's "hard for any cable series to amass large
numbers these days," but the facts are still
hard to ignore.
The outlet wrote:
"The bad news is that these ratings are down
fairly substantially from the 0.8 rating that
the show generated for its season 4 premiere
back in February 2016.
It's also down about 9 percent in total viewers.
Versus the average season 4 rating, the Vikings
premiere is down about 13 percent in the demo
and 4 percent in the viewers."
This wasn't a new trend, either: the previous
season also saw a significant drop.
According to TV Series Finale, season 4 of
Vikings was down by a whopping "28 percent
in the demo and 44 percent in viewers."
History renewed anyway, but the network must
have recognized that the show was approaching
its end.
One surefire way of getting waning viewers
to stick with a show is to announce that the
next season will be the last, and it seems
the network wanted to wrap Vikings up before
it saw a mass exodus.
Gustaf Skarsgård's Floki has been a fan favorite
since day one, but the character underwent
wholesale changes in season 5.
He sails with Ragnar's sons as part of the
Great Heathen Army, but once they avenge him,
Floki becomes little more than a spare part.
"I feel trapped in all this happiness.
I feel trapped, Helga."
He then takes to the seas alone and puts himself
at the mercy of the Gods, who lead him to
what he believes to be Asgard, but we know
today as Iceland.
Floki decides to bring a handful of settlers
to this new, wild land, hoping to build a
community free of the violence that had become
an everyday part of Viking life.
Despite Floki's attempts at keeping the peace,
petty arguments turn into blood feuds and
the settlement struggles.
It ought to have run across a few episodes
at best, but the Iceland plot was still ongoing
at the end of season 5, testing the patience
of many viewers.
One ticked off Redditor wrote:
"I can't believe I gave Hirst the benefit
of the doubt with this storyline.
The drama between Eyvind and Floki has been
forced from the start, and they've made absolutely
no effort to get us to care about any of the
new characters."
Floki's voyage to Iceland may have been inspired
by true events, but sadly it made for some
pretty boring television.
When Travis Fimmel departed Vikings, Katheryn
Winnick became the new anchor of the show.
Ragnar's first wife Lagertha has always been
loved by fans, so this seemed a smart move.
But while Winnick made a name for herself
playing Lagertha, like Fimmel, it was only
a matter of time before she too moved on to
bigger things.
Vikings may have sailed a little off course
in season 5, but Winnick remains in demand.
The Dark Tower was a letdown for her and Polar
didn't exactly go to plan, but Winnick is
set to return to TV with a brand new Netflix
show in 2019, Wu Assassins, a martial arts
crime series set in San Francisco's Chinatown.
Winnick's in-show son Alexander Ludwig is
also a hot property thanks to his portrayal
of Bjorn Ironside.
Ludwig had previously appeared in the Hunger
Games franchise, but Vikings catapulted him
to new levels of fame.
He told Channel 24:
"I'd never experienced anything like that.
It's amazing how much this show has really
affected people in all walks of life globally."
It’s not a stretch to imagine that Ludwig
must be in as much demand as Winnick and Fimmel.
When the first episode of The Last Kingdom
aired in 2015, some had already dismissed
it as a Vikings knockoff.
By the time the first season was done, however,
many minds had been changed.
In its review for the show, The AV Club wrote:
"BBC America's sprawling, arresting eight-part
historical miniseries The Last Kingdom proves
that there's room enough on television for
more than one Viking invasion.”
The show (which is based on the Saxon Stories
novels by Bernard Cornwell) was praised by
critics across the board, creating an instant
rivalry with Vikings.
Of course, Vikings and The Last Kingdom aren't
the only two shows set during that tumultuous
period in European history.
When Erik Kain expressed relief over Vikings
ending in his Forbes piece, he pointed out
that the market was becoming highly saturated.
Kain wrote:
"We have The Last Kingdom airing still on
Netflix after all.
Oh, and there's also the wonderful Norsemen.
Viking shows are becoming like zombie shows."
Norsemen is a comedy show, so it wasn’t
ever really a direct threat to Vikings, but
its success further proves that History isn't
the only network capable of creating a compelling
show about the Viking way of life.
The Viking trend has also hit the big screen
with Northmen: A Viking Saga arriving hot
on the heels of Vikings in 2014, and Norse
culture remains prevalent in Hollywood today
thanks to the How to Train Your Dragon franchise.
Viewers have lots of different places to go
should they want a Viking fix, and Vikings
itself has suffered for that fact.
Despite everything, many Vikings fans still
believe the show is being sent to Valhalla
far too soon.
Disgruntled viewers took to Twitter to vent
when the news broke, comedian Kathleen Madigan
among them.
She tweeted:
"Vikings [is] being canceled after season
6.
I'll just go ahead and prepare my own viking
funeral in solidarity.
Sad news."
And while some fans might point out that the
show has already covered everything historians
know about Ragnar and his sons, that doesn't
necessarily mean Vikings has to end.
Hirst’s other show The Tudors was notorious
for being historically inaccurate, but even
leading historians admitted that the things
Hirst added worked well for TV.
Dr. Tracy Borman told The Telegraph:
"Yes, the scriptwriters may have taken liberties
with the facts, but they have also succeeded
in re-creating the drama and atmosphere of
Henry VIII's court."
Vikings star Alexander Ludwig has praised
Hirst's willingness to take a "creative liberty"
with the show, which he could well have continued
to do for many more seasons.
The decline in ratings was undoubtedly on
the mind of History executives when they agreed
to bring Vikings to an end, but Michael Hirst
didn't mention any of that when he sat down
with Variety in January 2019.
Officially, the interview was about the season
5 finale, but the show's cancellation inevitably
came up.
Pressed for details, Hirst claimed that six
seasons was actually enough time for him to
tell the story he'd wanted to tell from the
very beginning.
He said:
"What I was trying to do was write the saga
of Ragnar Lothbrok and his sons.
After six seasons and 89 episodes, that's
what I felt, finally, I'd done…
I had no reason to want to continue it beyond
that."
"Don’t waste your time looking back.
You’re not going that way."
Hirst was quick to remind Variety readers
that the funeral pyre hadn't been lit just
yet.
In an effort to lift spirits among the wounded
fans, the showrunner started hyping up the
sixth and final season.
He told the publication:
"We visit three new worlds in those episodes,
we go through great tragedies and great heroism,
and if you have tears to weep be prepared
to weep them as you watch season 6.
I'm very proud of the show.
I did what I wanted to do, that's the truth."
Losing Vikings is a huge blow for the show's
many dedicated fans, but it was softened by
news that a spinoff series is in the cards.
When Variety asked Hirst what he had planned
for this new show, the writer and producer
said that he considers it a "continuation
series."
"We were defeated!"
"We live to fight another day."
Hirst went on to explain that he had developed
an attachment to the characters he brought
to life in Vikings, which is why he wanted
to be involved in any new show set in that
world.
Hirst said:
"I have to say that they're not characters
to me.
I write so much about them, I've lived with
them for seven years.
They're real people to me.
So I care, and have been caring, about them
for a long time.
I want to guide them through whatever storylines
they have."
So does this mean we'll see more of our favorite
Vikings characters pop up in this continuation
series?
And what does 'continuation series' even mean?
Hirst explained:
"Continuation means that if we make it, it
will be connected to my saga.
It may not involve necessarily the same characters.
I can't go into more details than that, but
for the fans of the show it will be a continued
enjoyment of the Vikings experience."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.